warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
advised and there were many times where
directors would say things like pray to
the theater Gods you know invite them to
come to you and give you the energy that
you need to do this performance good
evening Godless sodomites kneel before
your God
Babylon making me the highest paid
megalomaniacal boy King in all of
Babylon you see if you go and visit the
very home of the Oscars where they hold
it each year you can see a plaque on the
wall that says the Babylonian courts the
camera shows you the stage and you see
an unmistakable Tower of Babel embedded
into the design outside of the Kodak
Theater you have the gate to Ishtar and
you have Babylonian Gods put on the
outside of the gate they have the exact
elephants they have the same exact gate
of Ishtar they have the same exact
Babylonian Gods over the top of the
gates did any of them have any and this
is probably way off have any type of
altars or any type of thing that they
had set up in in their own little uh
maybe their own little trailer maybe
their own maybe a separate Corner i'
I've heard about this happening
throughout history where not just in
acting but even in uh some uh well-known
uh heists that have happened these uh I
read a story just the other day about
these these bank robbers they had set up
this Altar and they had believed it gave
them special privilege to go get this
money and when they would go out they
were finally uh able to stop these guys
and this is this I I realized this is a
little bit of a rabbit Trail but I'm
coming back um they were able to stop
these guys cuz they finally figured out
where their car was and they ended up
being able to shoot all the FBI by going
around in the circle and one guy was
able to stop them because he shot them
uh in the neck but they found out that
all the FBI had riddled them through
with bullets but these guys kept going
one even went through the aorta but
these they kept going and kept and and
they shot several um it's it's a
horrible story but it's a well-known
documentary story where they went back
they said how are these guys able to do
this and that these guys were able to do
this because they had an altar and they
were praying to these gods of War those
deputies were able to tell me that the
only thing they found uh the only thing
they found at this uh at this place was
they found a little altar that was a
Norse a pagan sort of Norse god Altar
and it appeared that uh these two
individuals had at that time they did
some kind of sacrifice to uh to some uh
evil spirits uh from Norse mythology
that something to do with B cirker
spirits and
so so I I told them I said that's it
that's how they did what they did they
did some kind of sacrifice and these uh
these uh whatever was the god of
Mischief that they did these uh
sacrifices to uh I think it was called
lokai Loki and uh to the Berserker
spirits and they were given these
Berserker Spirits whatever they are uh
they were given that in order to
accomplish what they did and that's
that's what they did they had a complete
uh dedication uh on a spiritual level
that inhabited them came to them and
helped them to do these extraordinary
Feats that they did Loki specifically
interesting and uh they they said it has
some spiritualism that had something to
do with it and they they closed the case
as a paranormal case so it was
interesting but there is something
spiritual that that is absolutely inside
and that can happen to actors and you
can't deny it absolutely abolutely yeah
the entire theater is just filled with
spiritualism for sure right like I think
of Heath Ledger who as you may remember
he played uh the Joker in The Dark Night
and you might remember that he had a
tragic end to his life after his serious
commitment to his character I mean he
would lock himself in his hotel room for
weeks on end with little to no sleep and
he would be drawing crazy pictures and
making crazy notes in this diary mhm
dark things right dark things that you
would expect from somebody who's going
through serious mental illness and what
happened is a lot of people are
skeptical you know did he kill himself
or not but his last words in his diary
were
bye-bye and a lot of his castmates would
often say that he threw himself on the
walls in the set just to make his uh
injuries look more realistic for his
character wow and so I think that that
is the level of commitment that every
actor an actress aspires to even in the
small scale Productions that I was part
of I mean we took ourselves very
seriously yeah he was a method actor and
he actually um would show up on set if I
if I if I remember this correctly um
would not break character yes and in
fact I remember reading articles with
the other cast members that were on this
character and said he was downright
scary when he would show up you just
felt like this dark presence that was
with him my one experience with Heath um
the film was our scene together in the
hospital bed which is really my only
scene with them and it was um I was in
the hospital bed that day and I thought
well I don't really have any lines what
am I going to do and I had no idea what
was going to happen so I was got in the
bed and they were lighting and Chris was
walking around and doing things and then
Heath came around and Heath was always
in character so he would come around and
you know be talking to himself in the
corner like this and then he would come
up I was laying there and I was watching
him the whole time time and he came up
and would walk around me like
this and I would watch him and I would
watch him he'd walk around the hospital
bed like this I'd watch him didn't say
anything for maybe an hour he would walk
around and then we watch him and then
he'd start saying his lines and I would
watch him boom watch him come around to
bed like this and then all of a sudden
my hand would go up like this and he C
caught my hand so we just went through
this organic process of developing this
scene which was really
nothing and then when we came time to
shoot we had this thing beautifully
choreographed and you know he did we
never said a word to each other wow yeah
and then it was a long day and we walked
out um to our back to our trailers and
Heath was here and I was walking and he
puts his hand on my shoulder and he goes
that's what acting's all about I think
you know I saw um a a little pieces of
evidence where it's like he when he met
with Christopher Nolan and talked about
doing this performance um he said I have
a trick of my sleeve and you know
there's there's lots of videos of
Christopher Nan talking about this
experience when he called him like what
is it that you have and I honestly think
that he was messing around with invoking
spirits and he pulled something inside
of him that literally made him go insane
that's interesting that you bring that
up because I was actually taught the
same method that he used in his acting
it's called the stanislowski method and
basically to sum it up it's the art of
experiencing and so it really recommend
that you become one with your character
essentially my directors would
constantly tell us things like invite
your character in empty yourself oh wow
and let your character live out their
life in you mhm I took an acting class
that was uh centered around this kind of
theology or this kind of theology the
the method and um what was very
interesting was he would have us
actually come into the class and we
would do actions that we would do on a
daily basis like let's say just taking a
shower so you shower if you ever ever
paid attention to your showering in a
very sequential order that you pretty
much do every single day then he would
disrupt that and he'd say you need to
now have your character shower and you
need to let that character shower like
he would shower and then do wacky things
like this so that it was like basically
training your brain to like stop being
you and be this other person it's really
uh I think opening doors but this is at
all levels and it's wrong on all levels
and um did someone might view this with
Heath Heath Ledger as an EXT extreme
case but there are other cases we talked
about Michael B Jordan and how he it was
hard for him to dis associate from
kilmonger so it was no real plan I
didn't have a I didn't have an Escape
Plan either you know I wanted to be in
this lonely place as long as I could in
order to kind of capture the essence of
what Eric you know Stevens was what
kilmonger was so when when we WRA the
film you know I'm like in my mind I like
okay cool go back to you know regular
life get back to LA and be cool but it
was a little tough for me at first to
kind of like accept hard just to lay him
down and be done with it yeah how did it
take you a while it took me it took me
you know I mean I don't really know
exactly when I came out of it but you
know I went went to therapy you know
what I'm saying I started talking to
people started unpacking a little bit
there's a man who played Elvis even to
this day is still talking with the
accent of Elvis he can't remember who he
was before he totally immersed himself
into that character and lastly Elvis
Presley himself you were an an an icon
and a rebel and I love you so much Irene
Bartlett Austin's Voice coach recently
chatted with Australia's ABC Gold Coast
on Monday and she addressed how the
actor's voice permanently changed since
playing such an iconic role telling the
outlet because of covid shutdowns he was
working on it all the time and it's
difficult to switch off something you've
spent so much focus and time on Irene
continued on defending her students
technique and said it wasn't being done
for show adding what you saw in that
2023 Golden Globe speech that's him it's
genuine it's not put on I feel sorry
people are saying that you know it's
still acting but he's actually taken the
voice on board I don't know how long
that will last or if it's going to be
there forever Jim Carrey has a very or
had a very difficult time stopping being
um what was the comedian that he played
um um Andy Kaufman in fact when he
played the Grinch uh he would not show
up some days and and Ron Howard would be
like hey dude aren't you going to come
to work you know everybody's out here
with the lights on and everything and
he'd say well uh Jim carre's not here
and he'd be like well who's there and
he'd be like Andy Kaufman will you
please send Andy Kaufman out to do the
scene and literally he'd do the scene as
Andy Kaufman when when Man in the Moon
came out there was all this talk about
the process that you went through when
you became Andy coffin D did you ever
have it in the back of your mind back
then that you wanted to share that story
and this way that you're getting to do
now yeah and I thought I thought I had
become Andy Kaufman but there was no me
actually at the end of it all I realized
that there was you know that this
character was making choices to play a
character and uh you know so that's what
kind of happened and that's what Chris
found in this interview and in this
footage that there was actually a
existential not a crisis but a discovery
going on you know cuz he couldn't stop
like the there was there was a blurred
line between where he began and the
character he just played I remember Jim
Carrey going out to that that one show
and saying who are we really I don't
even know who I am I I don't know what
is what is Jim Cary I can relate to that
so much there were so many times
throughout my childhood that I thought I
actually don't even have a clue who I am
I am all these other people but who is
Ashley and I couldn't answer that and I
think of the verse John 17:21 which says
when Jesus prayed that they may all be
be one as you father are in me and I in
you and that they also may be one in us
that the world may believe that you sent
me so it's Christ that wants us to be
one with him and if there's anything
else that we're trying to be one with
then I think that's very problematic
yeah
[Music]